おはようございますはじめしゃちょーです
3億円のお家の物全部出したらどれぐらい
あるの
嘘でしょ嘘じゃないです皆さんおはよう
ございますはじめしゃちょーです朝7時
ですなんでこんな早朝から動画を撮って
いるかと言いますとお笑いのからです本日
はもう皆さんご存知の通りはじめしゃ
ちょーの3億円のおうち僕この家に住んで
からだいたいもう1年半ぐらい経つんです
けれどもさすがに1年半もすると家に生活
感が出てきたんですよもちろんまだ全然物
が置いてない部屋とかもあるし中にも
めちゃくちゃはじめシャツを武士が聞いて
物で溢れかえってる部屋もあります
めっちゃ広くてたくさん物が入って正直4
階建てたと思うどこに何があるか全く
分からない物の管理ができてないどれだけ
モドがあるのか私は思いましたので今日1
回2/3のもの全部出してみてどれくらい
今物があるのか実際に見てみたいと思い
ます皆さん何でそんなことするって思うと
思いますけれども皆さんにはわからない
でしょう家が広すぎてどこに何があるか
わからない今日連絡よく言うんだけど多分
俺のせいもあるんだけど場所の問題なのよ
広
すぎた人どこに何がそしてこの家の収納力
見てみたくないですかちょっと気になら
ないどれくらい入ってるかよ目に見てね
もう先に自分の大事なものだけまとめてき
ましたコリュックとスーツケースの中に
何かゲーム機とか大事なものはまとめてき
たのでこれはこれ絶対外に出しちゃダメな
ものあるのよパソコン機材周りとかあと
wi-fiとかも外したくないパソコン
周り
wi-fiカメラ機材備え付けの冷蔵庫が
出せないのでそれはもう諦めますそれ以外
のものベッド家具冷蔵庫テレビ全部家の外
に出してみるとどれくらいの量になるのか
3億円のお家の外に並べてちょっと比較し
てみたいと思います
[音楽]
多分1日かかるぜ
はいというわけでなんとなく見てみ
ましょうかもうね
[音楽]
玄関はまだ少ないよねだいぶ綺麗に使って
いるというかそもそも物を置く場所でも
ないからね
ルカリオとかヨギボーとかがあるぐらい
やっぱ玄関って人がよくお客様とかが通ら
れるのでここだけは
高いおしゃれな置物とか置いてあります
意外と少ない説ないいやわかんないんだよ
ね
ちょっと俺がいつもよくいる部屋どっち
かって言うと作業部屋になりますはいここ
をよく俺が撮影したりしてる部屋ですここ
は俺っぽさが出てるよねほらこういう
ちょっと何
ぬいぐるみ並べてみたりとかゲームした
形跡フィギュアとかぬいぐるみとかが
置いてありつつもう目で俺コカコーラ
らしいんじゃないぬいぐるみがやっぱ多い
ね
ぬいぐるみが多いですけどこういうのは
ちょっとマジで外に出したくないやつここ
だけで多分3400万ぐらいあるぞこれ
ここもカメラ機材ですねここら辺も
ちょっと外に出したくないこういうのは
もうほんと出さないようにしていきたいと
思いますただそんなバカでかい場所とる
こととかないと思うのでほぼ農家作業
スペースパソコンとかもう俺バックに入れ
たから大丈夫まあこういうソファーとか
投げつけとかこういうのがトータルでどれ
くらい場所が取ってるのかかなり大事に
なってくる気がしますはい2階です
2回ももう結構だだっ広いからねそんなに
超物があるわけではないと思いつつ最近
買った大量のロッカーこれ出すのやばいね
でもこんな大きいロッカーこの量を置いて
も空間の余裕こっちの和室にはまあヨギ
ボーとか巨大なカエルとかはじめしゃ
ちょーグッズのメルカリで返しみたいやつ
もろもろ置いてあるなっていう感じです
これは出しますちょっと
減らしとこ
[音楽]
ウォーターサーバーめっちゃ精密機械だと
思います
綺麗な水を維持するのすごい難しいので
いや普通の家だとありえないサイズの食器
あるからね本当にまあここら辺も実際外に
出して初めて物の大きさがわかると思い
ますうちの一番大きな冷蔵庫も備え付けで
これ外出せねえような出せない無理無理で
良かったこれ動いたらその時点で出します
から3階です
編集スペースですねうちのスタッフがよく
いる部屋パソコンとかは出さないけど
こいつ系は出すよかなり場所取ってるんで
こういうのは大事ここ結構出たもの多い
イメージそれでもこの空間の余裕さよ
すごくない
普通さこんなでっかい机4つとか入れると
溢れちゃうじゃんものでこんだけ余裕が
あるというすごいもうここに関しては何の
部屋か俺もわかってないなんか机とか石と
か最近使わないもの置いてある部屋になり
ますここもね普通の家学校机ないですから
学生6人分ここに収納できるからねこれ
全部外に運び出します続いて4回です4階
も地味に物こういう照明とかなんかタンス
とかここら辺もねはいうちの金庫はここに
置いてありますこことかごめんなさい
外出したくないですあの
復元不可能な類ですね1回これ外出せたら
つけるのに1週間ぐらいかかりそうなので
ちょっとごめんなさいこの
配信機材精密機械の判定でここもちょっと
なってさせてくださいすいません申し訳
ないです本当にすいません申し訳ないです
本当にすみません申し訳ないですこれとか
さだってさ買った意味えっとここが大地の
豚箱です
ねって言われた気がするけどな自分の
テリトリだったら
[音楽]
学校が大好きな書斎ですねここも地味に物
が多いので全部運び出したいと思います
はい寝室です寝室はベッドが2個あります
ね4階にこれがあるのがでかいんだけど
はいというわけでブルーシートしっかり
引きました
各外に出すとき汚したくないから
床をしっかりと綺麗に
今のところは俺のスーツケースとリュック
しかないんですけどもこれからここがどう
なってくるのかマジで書くの数わかんない
のでちょっと楽しみです
日付が変わらないことを切に願います行っ
てきますまずは玄関乗るのを運びます
玄関はもの少ないので多分ちゃちゃっと
終わりますでしょう
はい
[拍手]
[音楽]
玄関は多分終わりましたやばいマジで買っ
た時の感じになった1回まだたくさんある
のでやっていきますはいというわけで1階
のよく俺が編集とか撮影とかしてる一番
よくいる部屋です小物がかなり多いんです
けども頑張って出していきたいと思います
[音楽]
[拍手]
全部なくなっちまった
[音楽]
全部なくなっちまったあんなにもので呆れ
てたのに全部なくなりましたこの棚も全部
なくなりましたもう全部なくなっちゃった
本当に
来た時より綺麗になっちゃったよこれもう
意外と30分ぐらいででもバーって外に
出せましたねでも多分1回で外が近いから
すぐ出せたのもありますね一応この
インターホンとか
wi-fiだと残してますごめんなさい
その子は完全に綺麗になりました
新築はいというわけで1階のものを
だいたい出し終わったと思うのでちょっと
外に置くとどれくらいなのか見てみたいと
思います
1回分でこねるってのが分かったらね
[音楽]
なるほどねーなるほどなるほど
まあこんな感じになりました
いやでも1回でも結構うまるっちゃあるね
やっぱ物多いのかな1回でだいたいこれ
ぐらいものが入ってましたただここから2
回さんが4回と物が増えていくんです
けれどもどうせだったら俺最後に見たいよ
ね全部溜まってるの
突撃が見るとつまんないので2回3回4回
全部出してから最後どれくらい貯まったか
見たいと思いますじゃあ234回行ってき
ます2回行きました2階のキッチンです
まあコーラがたくさんあるのとあと食器と
か動画で使うようなわけわかんない巨大な
食器とかあるので結構実は物が多いのでは
ないかと思ってます
片付けていきましょう
[音楽]
キッチン終わりましたマジで1回より時間
がかかった気がしますコーラが多すぎ次は
2回の和室ですロッカーも運んでいきたい
と思います
[音楽]
終わりました2階和室も全て
机ももう何だろうなくしましたこんなに
広かったんですね何もなさすぎてすごいな
そして
キッチンも全てなくなりました
ウォーターサーバーくらいしか今残って
ないですねこれが本来の3億円のお家の2
階のある姿でございます次考えの編集
みんなが編集とかする部屋ですね結構機材
とかも
机とか多いので
頑張ります
[音楽]
はいなくなりました
ここはパパッと出しちゃいましょう
[音楽]
はい終わりましたここはもう何なら余裕
だったなぁスケートカーペット置いてある
ぐらいだったのでも一瞬で終わりました
いい感じじゃないでしょうかでは次は4回
行きましょう4回来ました4階のキッチン
もなんか地味に物があるので飛ばしていき
ます
[音楽]
はい
綺麗になりました
キッチンというけども俺こう使ったこと
ないんでそんなになかったです物が
チラチラあったなぐらい寝室ですテレビと
か机とかあるしバカでかいベッドが2個
あるので結構場所取りそうですねやって
いきましょう
[音楽]
昨日はいというわけで寝室で物全部
なくなりました
濃い響くないやーすごいなめっちゃ綺麗な
部屋だなこことっても綺麗ですね次行き
ましょうはい4回で一番物が多い部屋です
編集とか配信とかする部屋ですねこれ以外
は全部持ってきます
[音楽]
[笑い]
配信の機材以外終わりましたここも結構机
あったなもう
完璧に綺麗になりました広いなんて全部
広いなマジでどれくらいものあるんだろう
まっさらの部屋になってしまったんです
けどすみませんあのねこれだけはどうか
許してほしいですすいませんこれマジで
直せないのでこれはちょっとこのまま寝
させてもらってwi-fi以外は全て
完璧に外に運び出しましたクリアです次は
大臣の豚バコです
[笑い]
[音楽]
[拍手]
ごめんなさいごめんなさいごめんなさい
ごめんなさい終わった終わったごめん
ごめん本当にごめんなさい
[拍手]
花瓶の部屋全てなくなりました
いやすごいな
やっぱ物なくなるとこの家でかいな
何ということでしょうあのもので溢れてい
たはじめしゃちょーの3億円のお家から
全てのものがなくなってしまいました
決して無駄なものばっかりではなかったの
ですが必要なものも無駄なものも全て
排除することによって
3億円のおうち本来の美しさを取り戻した
のでありました
しかし何もないのは何もないので
寂しい
まるで売り出すんじゃないかと思うぐらい
の
綺麗さです
300億円で売りに出しましょう
[音楽]
はいというわけで3億円のお家から物が
全てなくなりましたwi-fiと精密機械
を除くはいもう超すっきりしました俺が
引っ越してくる前の状態より物が少なく
なりました3億円のおうち気になるのは
この家にあったものの数今まさに
尊敬のお家の前にこの家にあったもの全て
まとめて置いてあるのでちょっと見に行っ
てみたいと思いますはたして3億円のうち
にはどれくらいものがあったのでしょうか
すげー家の前は一応全部
埋まったぞ
すごいなでもなんか思ったより少ないのか
ないや多いなというわけで皆さんこれが
3億円のお家に入っていたもの全てです
全部外に出してみましたどうすんのこれ
どうすんのこれどうすんのこれちょっと見
てみましょうかマジであのねパッと見
フリーマーケットなのよこれマジで値札と
か履いちゃったら普通に近所の人来ちゃう
これちょっと中見てみましょうか物多すぎ
てもう迷路になってるんよやっぱポケモン
のぬいぐるみとか結構量すごかったですね
ここら辺とかカエルもめっちゃで終わった
からねえマジでフリーマーケットなんだ
けど
すごい
フリマでしかねえよ
お疲れ
真っ黒いそれ
あのね
バツ暑いすごいねどこをどうすればいいか
わかんないんだけどすごいねこういう間接
照明とかも全部外出しましたからはい
いやこんなにものには触れてしまいました
俺んちの目の前家の前で収まるぐらいの物
の量ってことがわかったので
意外とわかんない普通の家からすると絶対
多いと思うんですけどなんか俺の体感
そんなにものはなかったって感じはあり
ましたはいというわけで皆さんもお家の中
にものいっぱいあると思います家が2回
以上の人ってどれくらい家に物があるの
かってなかなかわからないと思うので皆
さん是非家の物を外に出してみてください
この後どうする逆にこれでさ今まで4階に
あって1階に持ってきたいものとかさここ
から仕分けるわけじゃんタグとか物の移動
もできますいらないものも捨てれますと
整理整頓もできるこれ一石二鳥もうこれね
いいことしかないんですねこれ頑張って
ここから家のもの全部家の中に戻したいと
思います形式がもう帰る
[音楽]